okay so this is the ember island players
you might notice that this is like the
exact same shot from two videos ago
that's because I actually in terms of
what I'm shooting these they're a touch
out of order but what do you care so
okay the I watched the episodes in order
though that's all the important so we
have the this episode that actually I've
been told about ahead of time I I wasn't
told any of the jokes I was just made
aware that this episode was coming like
everyone I go to cons everyone tells me
this episode's kind my brother told me
it was coming they're all like well
there's no spoilers and so it's okay and
they all said the same thing it's a
total filler episode it has nothing to
do with anything it's just a cute little
thing for Laughs and it kind of is I
mean they they address a little bit sort
of the romance between Katara and Aang
which wasn't really digging by the way
but I'll get to that in a second so they
told me that to go this place where in
the Fire Nation where they they put on a
show this theatrical production of
everything that has happened so far but
it's through the fire nation's filter
dies and it sounded great and a lot of
it was great but I think it's very
possible people telling me about it
maybe you've ruined it for me um because
it's it's still good it's like okay but
I guess where I thought what I was gonna
get like you just hear that idea is like
oh my god that sounds hilarious and some
parts are legitimately hilarious but I
other parts are just kind of slow and
it's like what was that joke about or
what was there even a joke there I
unless the jokes
unless there's so many in jokes I'm just
not getting them all which is totally
possible
but most of my felt I got and they were
the wasn't require were so clever
especially now that I know the fan
reaction to a lot of this stuff it kills
me the the Great Divide was it the Great
Divide episode where they're flying over
it's like look at that Great Divide down
there yeah we should skip that and they
I mean obviously they got feedback of
people saying we don't make they never
show their um the way they make fun of
their own choices I love it when the
rock falls on the guy playing jen is it
to jet dies never really made clear it
so clever I mean that that stuff is so
wonderful and I like I like that they
incorporated a lot of real theater
techniques and they have like kabuki
acting in there and it's all that stuff
it is really clever
um I like but I like how they also make
fun of like sir current theatre
techniques like having a woman play
obviously satirizing Peter Pan and she
flies around the theatre IV that hugely
funny um that the moments where I sort
of felt it fell flat though was that
there are some parts where just so it
looks like they tell what happens or
they just sort of keep reusing a joke
and it's not it just for me and never
quite hit a bull's-eye um
and okay for example I know this is part
of the joke but Toph laughing as hard as
she can at everyone's uh port rails and
saying how funny they are and then when
she pops up I happy when they're gonna
do this just this big strong guy he
comes William Toth you know what was
funny but the fact that the fact that
she was not offended by it I know what
they were going for but it just didn't
work for me it she should have been
offended by it I know they're doing it
because they're expecting she's gonna be
offended and they give you something
else but it it would have been funnier
she was offended uh because her angry is
it is very funny um and by sort of not
giving it okay it plays with an
expectation but it's not it's not
necessarily funny at least for me it
maybe it was funny for you guys I don't
know um so you got this play and it's
you know it's like I said there's about
four or five times I'm like wow that's
really funny like that's really clever
really funny I love you know they're the
portrayal is from you know this person
this person is surprised
knowledgeable carriage salesmen I need
that hugely fine very very very funny um
but you sort got a really wait for them
sort of through these very slow either
awkward jokes or just moments as just
sort of showing what happened or isn't
it kind of funny how the play is set up
and it's not quite portraying it right
but what what's the humor in part of how
it's not being portrayed well I don't
know I'm being I'm being really probably
really nitpicky about this but I think
it's because if it does episodes been
build-up for me and there is no I mean
god they weren't kidding when they say
was a filler episode it's like once it's
done you have that big thing where well
I thought the play is over it's like no
apparently there's more and I'm like was
this building up to and shows the
Firelord defeat everyone goes yay and I
thought are they building up to a punch
why are they building up to something
where Aang is gonna realize something
else he has to do or he's gonna realize
his responsibility I said no they just
walk out and say what a bad play and
that's it and oh come on that's so much
build-up either give something connected
to the episode or like you know a real
good punchline I just thought that was
not that was not strong enough um so
okay so so you got that uh but then the
other thing you got going on you got
this uh you got this bit where Toph is
talking with Zuko about about his uncle
and it's it's kind of rushed a touch I
felt like it couldn't you you could
explain this a little bit more you know
but again if you it can't seems like if
you take it out it's no huge loss um it
seems like the frie other more important
scenes um unless it comes back but I
don't I don't see it's such a minor
scene and it doesn't seem like a
comeback and and then you have this bit
with a Aang and Katara where Katara
saying that she's just confused and she
doesn't know what she wants and so forth
um so where where did this come from
exactly I mean granted they weren't
always focusing on the romance in this
but I mean it seemed like they were okay
I mean okay they weren't holding hands
or anything but I mean they
seemed like they kissed you know a
couple times or indicated that they were
interested in each other you know I said
I mean in the cave and you know before
he flies off to fight the Fire Lord you
know they kiss and they seem okay
suddenly she's confused it's like where
did this come from uh and it just
doesn't seem necessary to me it seems
like you have something nice going while
they keep developing it and by her just
saying I'm confused and nothing else
it doesn't Alan oh it doesn't hold water
for me no pun intended
it seems very much like you know she
says that it's part of war we're in a
battle we're in a war and there's so
much going on it's hard for me to focus
and okay but we're at a point was that
indicated it's just sort of this one
sentence and that's about it so I don't
know that that didn't gel well with me
so this this is just an OK Epis and I
know so many people are like that's one
of my favorite that's one of the great
ones I just yeah I think it's just okay
um and I I'm totally fine if it's just a
filler episode honestly you know you've
heard me say it before yeah this is
filler but it's still great come on
um I mean this is like the epitome of
filler I mean there's like almost
nothing connects to anything it's well I
mean it's obviously a recap of what's
happened but you know nothing moving
forward if you took this episode out
it'd probably be fine with the exception
of I guess the Aang and Katara stuff um
but even then that's in there for just a
little bit so yeah not not one of my
favorites I don't think it's a great
idea I really love the idea and some of
the moments are so perfectly done
particularly the fourth wall moments I
think are so smart and I love I love a
team that can laugh at themselves and
the choices they've made and the fan
interactions I mean yet well preaching
to the choir I love doing that stuff I
love seeing people who do that stuff but
yeah it's those moments are great the
jokes of fell flat just kind of fall
flat and doesn't really move the story
forward too much so it's it's not bad
it's just okay so sorry I couldn't be
more optimistic
about er sorry I can be more upbeat
about it but it's Tomatoes just in
alright episo-- maybe if I didn't know
going in maybe would have made a
difference I don't know I still probably
was seen as the same but uh alright
that's about all I got so getting close
to the end of your kids getting close to
the end of of Avatar here it's exciting
I'm really excited I love this show I I
know I've said a million times but I'm
I'm so excited to see how it's all gonna
end and all how it's all gonna come
together so uh real excited I'll see you
probably at the I think the beginning of
the finale is next so I'll just see you
there take care